it is entirely possible that you have
either bought a very expensive bottle of
wine or plan to open a bottle of wine
but not drink it all in one sitting
neither of these behaviors are
particularly familiar to me but I've
heard of them here's the problem with
that you open a bottle of wine oxygen
gets in and it can make the wine go bad
what you want to do is just place all of
that and get some other gas in there to
keep your wine fresh here's how you do
that with one of these this is a not Han
Solo's gun it's a it's a Corbin mark -
$330 and it uses cylinders of argon gas
to get rid of the oxygen and keep your
wine fresh here's what you do
pop the argon gas capsule into the
device when you pressurize a bottle even
something that's heavy glass can kind of
break so this case protects your hands
press the trigger to clear the needle
aha push down it's blowing a little
argon in there to replace whatever the
liquid displaces and the cool thing
about this is you're supposed to be able
to just take this back out the cork
reseals and so now you can just keep
this Corbin says that an individual
argon canister lasts for like three
bottles worth so that's you know Tuesday
and you know then you can just keep
going back to it basically letting argon
be argon
I guess I'm a little sorry about that